Our fifth look at what does a patient recognizes that every patient is a life
history that unfolds from egg through fertilization,
birth growth,
maturation,
reproduction,
and on into old age and death.
These patient life histories have evolved and they continue to evolve and that
evolution has both medical causes and medical consequences.
Okay.
Patients are phenotypes,
they are traits,
not jeans and treat.
Evolution is what's analyzed by life history theory.
Life history theory has successfully explained why organisms are smaller,
large,
why they mature early or late,
why they have few or many offspring,
why they have a short or a long life and why they must grow old and die.
Okay,
so what is it that causes life histories to evolve?
Well,
at a very,
very basic level,
they result from the interaction of extrinsic and intrinsic factors from things
in the environment and things in the organism.
The extrinsic factors are those that influence age or stage specific rates of
mortality and reproduction,
so risk and nutrition and things like that.
This is where the environment comes in.
Nutrition,
disease,
violence,
medicine,
public health.
Those are all factors that are affecting age and stage specific rates of
mortality and reproduction.
The intrinsic factors primarily include tradeoffs among traits and here
phylogeny genetics,
development in physiology are all involved in establishing these critical
connections among traits.
The analysis done is one of costs and benefits.
For example,
what are the costs and benefits of maturing earlier or later of investing more
in each of a few children or less in each of more children.
Those are standard life history questions and so you can see the framework is
one the conceptualizes organisms as having tradeoffs that set up a structure of
costs and benefits.
The method of analyzing treat evolution that's developed for life history traits
suggest how all traits evolve,
including traits in the immune system,
treats having to do with physiology and so forth.
Those can all be cast into this sort of framework.
Yeah.
An example of treat evolution is agent size at maturity.
We'll focus just on this one.
Natural selection shaped the evolution of agent size of maturity to maximize
reproductive success.
That results from maturation at different ages and sizes.
It's a very straightforward approach.
How many children and grandchildren are you going to get if you mature at this
age and size rather than at some other?
That's the question.
So let's make a few assumptions about costs and benefits.
First,
delaying maturity improves offspring's survival.
So older organisms have higher quality offspring.
Delaying maturity improves offspring.
Number.
Older organisms have more time to grow so they're bigger so they can have more
babies.
Earlier.
Maturity shortens generation time.
That's a benefit and early maturity shortens the period of risk before
reproduction begins,
so you're more likely to reproduce because you've survived to reproduce if you
can do it faster.
So these things are trading off with each other.
They're in opposition.
There is an equation down here which probably looks a little formidable.
It's the oiler latke equation.
It explicitly relates fitness to these traits.
Now in this equation,
fitness is this thing here a little our,
that's the rate at which a variant will grow in the population and in a stable
population.
This relationship between age fecundity survival and fitness can be shown to be
true.
Basically what you do is you are integrating between h at first reproduction.
In agent last reproduction of reproductive success.
That's probability of survival times fertility weighted by the discount or the
population growth rate and in a stable population that will equal one.
This gives a way of relating little r which is fitness in this formulation to
age of maturity Alpha.
Let's do that for these curves here.
So these curves come out of that equation is age of maturity Alpha and here's
fitness little are and what you can see is that under two different sets of
assumptions,
this is one which is based primarily on an effect on juvenile mortality and this
is one which is based primarily on fecundity.
You can see that there is a peak fitness associated with a certain age at
maturity.
The actual agent maturity is this dash line.
Here you can see that the model is bracketing that observed agent maturity.
This particular analysis for the western fence lizards.
Now you can ask yourself what will happen when a range of environments is
encountered.
So here we have long the x axis,
age along the y axis we have weight,
these curved lines here,
our growth curves.
So they indicate how much,
how wait is varying with age.
It's increasing rapidly here with age,
with rapid growth and a little more slowly here with slow growth.
Let us suppose that organisms decided that they were always going to mature at
the same weight.
Well,
if they're growing rapidly,
they would mature young and if they were growing slowly,
they would mature,
are quite old.
And the problem they would encounter as mortality,
let's suppose that they decided on the other hand to mature,
always at the same age.
Well,
if they mature when they're at this point,
when they're growing rapidly,
they're big,
but at the same age,
when they're growing slowly,
they're small.
So here the problem is that they lose fecundity there.
They aren't able to make as many offspring.
So just on that very simple ground,
one would expect a flexible compromise.
Something in between.
Now what the human females actually do,
they are phenotypically plastic.
This is rose Frisch's data on women in England and Scotland from the 19th
century and from Hutterites in Iowa from the 20th century.
And the women in England and Scotland in the 19th century were stressed by poor
nutrition and hard work.
And the women in Iowa and the 20th century were growing better and they weren't
as stressed.
And basically what you can see here are different measures of the,
this is procreative power on this axis over here,
this is age down here and marked on here are best fitness for procreation.
Okay?
So this is a shift here of about four or five years.
In other words,
in the 20th century,
women were able to mature and have children four or five years earlier than they
were in the 19th century.
And that is a plastic response.
So if you use that framework that you saw with the equation and the example from
the Lizard,
and you ask,
what is the optimal reaction or infer maturation in humans,
it is this blue line here.
And if you put in the amounts,
the,
the correct,
uh,
estimated parameters for the 19th and the 20th century,
this model predicts about,
uh,
four or five,
six years shift in agent maturation age at first birth.
Now,
what that means is that when human females grow faster,
they mature younger and larger,
and this is quite consistent with an optimal evolved reaction.
Them interestingly,
there is also on this figure another line,
it's this red line.
This is the difference made by nurture.
This red line indicates what one expects.
If juvenile mortality rates remain low,
there should be a shift of the entire reaction norm down to the left,
meaning that women should be maturing slightly earlier and slightly shorter,
slightly smaller than they were before juvenile mortality rates dropped.
So you can think of this as being selection that is a result of improvements in
medicine and public health.
We got a surprising confirmation of this when we analyze women in the Framingham
heart study.
We looked at selection operating on those born between 1890 in 1950 and then
projected the change that they would experience over the next Gen 10 generations
in height and an age at first birth height predicted to decreased by about two
centimeters age at first birth by a bit over five months.
We then contrasted that
with rates of evolution in 19 natural populations of plants and animals.
This is for height.
This is for age at first birth in humans.
Here you have intervals over which change was measured.
Here you have the rate of change.
The scatter of black points gives you all the measurements for plant and animal
populations in nature.
The humans are sitting right in the middle of them.
Humans have normal rates of evolution projected,
uh,
when compared with other organisms.
Contemporary humans are still evolving and they are evolving in the direction
that had been predicted by that model of life history,
evolution.
This is what an optimal reaction norm for and size of maturity looks like for
many organisms,
the dotted lines or a growth lines,
the dark line here is the optimal reaction norm.
So basically what it is saying is that if you're growing fast,
mature,
young and large,
and if you're growing slow,
mature,
old and small,
there are other possible reaction norms.
But this is certainly one that seems to be common.
Now,
why is there earlier age at first birth in contemporary humans?
Well,
agent size at maturity are determined by tradeoffs between infant mortality and
age of mother.
The offspring of younger first time mothers suffer higher mortality rates.
That's the trade off with juvenile mortality.
So here is a curve of infant mortality versus age of mother at birth for the
population of the US in 1960 61 with a sample size of a bit over 100,000.
And you can see that girls who are having offspring before they're 10 years old,
uh,
have a very high probability that their baby will die.
That drops down to a minimum at about 22 years of age and then begins to rise
particularly strongly after 35.
So what's going on when medicine improves?
Early Childhood survival is something that has a direct impact on the evolution
of agents size at maturity when modern hygiene and medicine,
lower infant mortality rates,
they reduced the evolutionary costs of earlier met earlier maturation.
But the benefits of earlier maturation stay the same.
So the cost benefit analysis,
uh,
ratio changes,
it's become possible and it pays off to mature earlier
with the cost of earlier maturation reduced.
And the benefits unchanged maturation shifts at earlier ages.
The entire reaction norm then moves down and to the left.
Similar effects have also been found in other human populations,
particularly those that like the u s population have already moved through the
demographic transition,
Finland and Australia,
so the important points from this lecture or that what evolves is not a fixed
value of a trait but the entire plastic response,
the reaction norm,
reaction norms depict the interaction of nature with nurture of genes with
environment and they are very useful for making the point that all aspects of
the phenotype result from gene environment interactions.
The nature nurture debate is a false debate.
Both things are important.
Public health measures and medical care have population level consequences.
They changed selection pressures and they alter the course of evolution.
That's something that most doctors probably don't realize.
The Framingham study describes the biology but at the same time culture is
pushing women in the other direction to have their first child later,
particularly in
families where both couples are professionals and women want to delay
childbearing for professional reasons.
The result is increased conflict between biology and culture.
So this is not a paradox that women are under selection to have earlier agent
maturation in Framingham,
Massachusetts in instead,
it is a pointer to the increased intensity of conflict between biology and
culture.
So to summarize,
selection shapes,
life histories from birth to death,
changes in life history events have costs and benefits and selection benefits,
uh,
shapes them to maximize the difference between the benefits and the costs.
That process is constrained by trade offs,
which connect traits that are genetically,
developmentally and physiologically bound together.
When traits are connected by tradeoffs,
then changes in one trade.
That improved fitness cause changes in other traits that decrease fitness.
We'll see that in greater detail in the next lecture.
What evolves is often not a fixed trait,
but it's plastic response.
It's norm of reaction,
how it is expressed as a function of the environment encountered.
So the take home from this lecture is a patient is not a fixed object.
Developmentally the patient is a point on a reaction norm that describes all the
different possibilities that that genotype had in interacting with various
environments.